the Marvel Cinematic Universe is streak
of near universally adored releases may
one day end but not this year
early preview audiences have taken to
Twitter in droves to rave over
spider-man far from home with many
pegging it as the very best cinematic
outing for the wall-crawler so far and
considering the fact that Sony Pictures
animation spider-man into the
spider-verse recently took home a Best
Animated Feature Oscar that's really
saying something
while there's still a moratorium on
critical reviews this didn't stop fans
who got a sneak preview of the film from
absolutely losing their minds in the
vaguest possible terms for instance
two-time Emmy Award winning sports
reporter Heather Catlin tweeted far from
home is by far my favorite spider-man
movie warning you'll have to watch at
least twice we know what you're thinking
what about Sam Raimi's spider-man 2
which some considered to be among the
finest superhero films ever made
you know that train scene is still
awesome
twitter user Kevin McCarthy TV has your
answer far from home has dethroned Sam
Raimi's spider-man 2 and is now my
favorite spider-man film what's insane
is that I can't even tell you why I'm so
in love with this film because it would
be a spoiler Gyllenhaal is incredible
Holland reconfirms as the best Spidey to
date amazing McCarthy was so excited he
even had to send a second tweet
expanding on his thoughts from the first
tweet heaping praise on director Jon
Watts I don't think I've been this
excited to rewatch a film since Jordan
peels get out and us Watts masterfully
layers incredible action storytelling
and character development into a film
that will be a whole new experience on
the second watch two of the best end
credits scenes ever geek bomb founder
Maude Garrett loved the film's tone
compared to the seriousness of Avengers
end game and was particularly enchanted
with Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio not to
mention the post-credit scenes
spider-man far from home is such a good
movie Jake Gyllenhaal suits up and
completely embraces his role in its
entirety and he's clearly having a blast
this is such a refreshing film after the
heaviness of endgame the post credits
scenes are a must watch and will blow
your dang mind
CNET reporter Sean keen agreed with
Garrett's assessment of Gyllenhaal's
performance and also reserved some
praise for zendaya as well major kudos
in particular to Jake Gyllenhaal for his
super engaging performance as complex
character Mysterio and zendaya who
brings depth in her massively expanded
role as MJ MJ I'm spider-man no of
course I mean it's kind of obvious
Brandon Davis of comicbook.com meanwhile
was just blown away by everything
spider-man far from home is an absolute
home run it's so much fun it's huge in
itself and for the future for the MCU in
the most surprising ways Tom Holland
Jake Gyllenhaal just a lethal awesome
combo I cannot wait to see this movie
again and again the playlist
editor-in-chief Rodrigo Perez felt this
one was even better than spider-man
homecoming but warned that spoilers
could be a major problem
spider-man far from home far superior to
its predecessor and really delightful
with a terrific theme of trust well
threaded throughout
could say more but it's spoiler Laden
full of fun secrets so be careful who
you follow and what they say and finally
ultra fan Preeti shiver summed
everything up calling it the most comic
book II movie Marvel has put out second
and third acts are outstanding the two
post credit sequences are going to stick
in my brain for a long time I cannot
wait to see this movie at least three
more times my jaw dropped and then
dropped again it's a paradigm shift yes
it appears that director John Watts star
Tom Holland and the rest of the crew
have absolutely knocked it out of the
park on this one and we can't say that
we're surprised after the massive
success of both Captain Marvel and
Avengers endgame it seems as though
Marvel is poised to have its third mega
blockbuster of the year and will be the
first in line to handover our money see
you there on July 2nd check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]